foreign
[Music]
for another tomes of Terror book review
so this is kind of weird but I feel like
choosing books at random like I do like
from my Kindle unlimited subscription
seems to be netting me a higher than
average percentage of novels by British
authors I'm not entirely sure why that
is
um I don't know if it's just because
maybe British writers are better at
coming up with titles and Concepts that
I find interesting or at least are more
capable of targeting my particular taste
whatever they may be I don't know what
it is but it so happens that the book
we're talking about today is by yet
another English writer whose name is
Alan Baxter
um he actually was born in England but
now he lives in New South Wales
Australia
now an interesting thing about reading
this novel uh which is called sallow
Bend and which came out in late summer
of 2022. is that the entire time I read
it because I didn't do like look up the
author until afterward until after I
finished it so I had no idea that a Brit
had written it and the setting of it is
like so
this is gonna sound weird but it's like
so specific but also so generalized that
I legitimately felt that it was taking
place in the U.S somewhere like maybe in
the northeast or perhaps in the midwest
or something like that now this
definitely did give me some like Stephen
king-esque evil small town Vibes
um particularly I think the works of his
that it reminded me of specifically were
mostly it and maybe like doctor sleep
there were some aspects of this that
were sort of sort of similar to Dr sleep
um and this also kind of had little
subtle hints of Something Wicked This
Way Comes The Ray Bradbury classic but
it kind of also has its own thing going
on
so if you like those kind of like cursed
small town sort of narratives then
you'll probably really dig this um it's
a pretty solid like supernatural horror
novel and it has a great great setup and
it just like draws you right into the
whole mystery like immediately so even
though the story kind of switches back
and forth between several characters
like depending on what's going on in the
story The main protagonist you know for
all intents and purposes is this guy
named Caleb Jackson now Caleb is a real
loner type of dude and kind of for good
reason he has some kind of
I guess you would call it a disability
and though it seems to share some like
the way it's described seem to share
some uh similarities with autism uh but
it's apparently not that like they kind
of go out of the way to say that it's
not that but they don't really know what
it is so basically what it is is Caleb
is really very extremely sensitive to
other people's emotions and also their
deceptions so he's like really good at
um telling what people are lying or
telling you know what's really going on
like with people's emotions so he can
easily tell what somebody is feeling or
hiding basically just by looking at them
but the thing about it is that people's
emotions and the lengths they go to to
cover them up and like this whole veneer
of like polite society and stuff like
having to navigate that is really
exhausting for him so he usually tries
to minimize human contact as much as
possible when he's and like when he's
forced to be in a crowd or like interact
with other human beings for any length
of time he starts getting a headache and
then like has to go be alone for a
little while to kind of like recharge
which you know that's a situation that I
can uh absolutely relate to by the way
I'm kind of the same way
um and he's also not very good at social
interaction
um basically because like I said he can
tell when someone's bullshitting and he
doesn't really understand this whole
song and dance about oh we have to
pretend to do this and you know you're
supposed to say this when this person
says that it's like he doesn't really
get that and he doesn't like it so it's
like he's really not very good at so
he's usually like really blunt or he's
just kind of like off in his own world
all the time which like I said I can
totally relate so I really kind of
related to this character like super
hard so I guess Caleb got born in like a
big city but you know the noise and like
the constant Crush of people was just
too much for him like too much of his
mental health so after an unfortunate
incident which is kind of mentioned near
the end of the book you don't really get
much detail about it but you kind of get
the gist he decided to move somewhere
where he could kind of have this very
quiet solitary life which is really all
he wants he doesn't have any big
Ambitions or anything like that he just
basically wants to be left alone so he
moves to this town sallow Bend and he
now works as the School Janitor and he
lives in like a little apartment like in
the basement of the school and like you
know takes care of the school and
everything now most of the people in
town
um think he's peculiar like some of them
think he like like might legit be
dangerous or like a pedo or something
but most people are just kind of like
well he's probably harmless they just
think he's kind of a weirdo but he
doesn't really mind that because
everybody leaves him alone and that's
really all he ever wanted now at the
beginning of the story uh saloband is
just all a buzz because two 13 year old
girls whose names are Claire and Suki
they're best friends they have gone
missing
so obviously everyone is very distraught
about this and they organize search
parties to like you know fan out and try
to track down these two girls
it also so happens that the annual
Carnival has just arrived in town and
this is led by a woman who's like very
uh acerbic very no-nonsense she's just
kind of like a tough Broad and she's
like kind of a cool character and her
name is Ashley strong
now the residents of sallow Bend
as much as they love attending the
carnival and it stays there for like two
weeks and it comes there every summer
and the townsfolks just love going there
everybody in town goes there despite
that they never really have entirely
trusted like the carnival people and
many of them find it very very fishy
that Claire and Suki the two 13 year old
girls disappeared on the same day that
the carnival came into town and started
setting up so some people think oh well
maybe the girls just kind of like snuck
out of their houses to watch the
carnival preparations or whatever and
just somehow got lost in the woods
because there's all these woods around
the town but a couple people do actually
suspect that maybe one of the carnies
might be responsible for their
disappearance
now because Ashley who runs the carnival
she knows how townspeople uh in general
like perceive the carnies so she's
basically tells everybody in the search
she's like I don't care what you just
like we're gonna even if we have to open
the carnival late or whatever we're
gonna help this town like find these two
girls so they'll see that we're not you
know monsters or anything like that so
they actually do volunteer to help out
and look around now because Caleb works
at the school and was acquainted with
the two girls he didn't know them know
them but like he'd seen them around and
stuff like that because he was pretty
familiar with all the students he kind
of feels obligated to join the community
in looking for them
so to this end he kind of goes and asks
what he can do about it and he gets sent
on a very reluctant errand he's like do
I really have to do this and they're
like yeah you do
um so he goes and like touches base with
this other local woman whose name is
Trisha and she's supposedly organizing
the search parties now as it turns out
she's not really there was just like
some wires crossed somewhere she's not
really organizing anything but she is
actually going down to the Town Square
to join in like and help out and
everything so she kind of likes
shanghai's Caleb into like buddying up
with her and kind of attempts to like
bring him out of his shell like she
don't really know him that well she's
just like oh you're the weird janitor
guy but you know and maybe he needs a
friend so she just kind of like drags
him along with us come on we'll be
search buddies or whatever and he's just
like oh Jesus like he doesn't want to do
it but you know he kind of like
grudgingly goes along now Trisha she
also has her own terrible [__] going on
by the way so a year prior to the events
of the novel her son Toby also
disappeared and has not been seen since
um also her husband Riley was unable to
deal with The Disappearance and he
started hitting the bottle hard uh
started becoming abusive like knocking
her around and stuff and is you know
pretty much in danger he's gonna lose
his job you know what I mean so they're
not going to have like enough money to
keep the house and all this other stuff
now so over the course of the book this
is actually quite cool like um there's
this really nice friendship that
develops between Trisha and Caleb who is
like I said this loner he's very very
reticent it's like really hard to get
him to talk and stuff like that but she
almost kind of like makes it her mission
to like I said bring him out of a shell
or at least like befriend him because he
doesn't really have any friends and I
really like the way this friendship
develops like over the course of the
novel and to me like in my opinion this
seems like the whole like emotional core
of the novel like the heart of it and I
really really liked that aspect of it so
a couple of days go by and to everyone's
relief uh the girls are actually found
alive uh by one of the carnies who's
like this you know kind of gentle giant
dude his name is Daniel now Claire and
Suki when they find them uh they're fine
uh but they said oh we got lost in the
woods for two nights and we found
shelter in this really creepy like old
Lakeside Cabin out there
um that pretty much everybody in town
has heard like spooky stories and
legends about like nobody really goes
out there because it's like too scary
and it's just like really weird around
there
here's the bizarre part though and this
is what I'm saying because this happens
like pretty early on in the story and
this is really what gets you in this
this is like a great setup
so two girls went missing right but when
Daniel found them there were three of
them
the third one is also 13 years old uh
she has a very distinctive uh White
streak in her hair much like mine today
I didn't even do that on purpose isn't
that crazy and her name is Hester
now Caleb is immediately very weirded
out by this development not only because
this girl seemingly kind of like came
out of nowhere obviously but also
because this is the even weirder part
everybody else in sallow Bend totally
acts like they've known Hester all their
lives like she's always been here in
town and that she totally did go missing
with the other two girls even though
Caleb is absolutely 100 certain that
that is not the case and that he has
never seen this girl before in his whole
entire life and like who the [__] is she
so it's really not a spoiler to say that
obviously um there's something very
strange about Hester for sure but for a
long time it's not entirely sure exactly
what that might be now shortly after the
girls are found
um the town is sort of plagued by a
series of really weird deaths um that
all appear to be like freak accidents or
suicides or something like that but
every time Caleb tries to talk to
somebody about how he believes maybe
Hester might be involved somehow and
it's like hey where did she come from
like she's never been here before and
like everybody's acting like they've
known her forever but whenever he asks
about it like the person he's talking to
gets like super forgetful or like their
mind wanders or they just like change
the subject or they get really
uncomfortable it's what were you talking
about again it was like that kind of
stuff
um and it's all um very disquieting and
Caleb doesn't know what the [__] is
going on now while all of that is going
on we're also following like some stuff
that's going on with the carnies and in
particular there's a guy who's like
works at the carnival and his name is
Saul and he's kind of an oddball hoop so
well he's really an oddball you know
what I mean and uh Caleb actually
suspects that he might have some kind of
maybe possibly Supernatural thing going
on too like not really sure about that
so as the story unfolds Caleb and Trisha
essentially have to like team up to try
to stop this evil whatever it is like
this Force that's been Unleashed in
sallow Bend as they seem to be the only
two people really
um completely aware that something
really uncanny might be going on in the
town Visa be this girl that just
appeared so as I mentioned earlier um
this definitely does feature elements
from some other classic stories like
kind of the cyclical Town curse aspect
of it maybe and like the carnival angle
of Something Wicked This Way Comes but
sallow Bend kind of takes all of those
ingredients I guess and kind of like
Cooks up its own recipe with them I
suppose
um so even though there are similarities
to other works I mean everything has
similarities to other works that's just
the nature of the Beast I guess but it
was this was a very like compelling
story in its own right
um the character of Caleb who's like I
said it does switch back and forth like
to different characters like some stuff
some Patricia's point of view some
stuffs from other people's point of view
but a lot of it is from Caleb's point of
view and he was like particularly
um a particularly relatable at least to
me and very like sympathetic character
um he's socially very awkward but but
he's like you know that he's like a
really good-hearted dude and you could
kind of really feel his distress and his
frustration when he felt like he was
pretty much like the only person in town
who could see what was really going on
and it was just like freaking him out
that like nobody else seemed to see
anything wrong
um also his friendship with Trisha I
really really liked that aspect as I
mentioned earlier I particularly liked
too that the author didn't try to like
shoehorn in a romance subplot because I
kind of felt like that was maybe where
it was going to go but I like that it
didn't do that it was like content to
just make them really good friends that
was like really refreshing because like
I said usually usually in a book of this
type it's like a lot of times they'll
try to like kind of shoehorn into
romance and I'm really glad that they
refrained that he refrained from doing
that uh some of the Kearney characters
as well uh specifically Daniel the guy
that uh found the girls and a little
person character named John Barrow who
kind of factors into the story later on
um we're also like really well
delineated characters and they're very
interesting I would have liked I think a
little bit more character element for
Ashley strong who was like the owner of
the carnival she's in it a little bit
but not she doesn't really play into it
all that much and I think I would have
liked and you know this is something
that is really
hard to quantify because I'm usually
it's kind of like well you can't like
over explain things you know what I mean
because then it gets like bogged down
and I don't really like that but I would
have liked slightly just slightly more
information about what exactly Saul's
deal was like the guy that works at a
carnival because whatever it was like
whatever he had going on um it was left
pretty ambiguous and I think I would
have liked just slightly more
information about that but it's not a
big deal I'm just saying you know it's
like I said maybe it's fine that it was
just like left Mysteries but yeah so
they don't really tell you exactly like
what is going on with him but I'm gonna
say like other than those tiny tiny
little nitpicks I really really enjoyed
this novel a lot
um and I was even actually got to say
like surprised by some uh pretty brutal
[__] that happened at the end and I was
like Jesus Christ was not expecting that
to happen you know what I mean so I
thought that was like really a good like
gut punch kind of ending as well so yeah
I would definitely recommend this uh
especially especially if you're into
like kind of old school Horror in so
sort of like you know Stephen King's
kind of like I said evil small town kind
of Vibes
um also very cinematic like the imagery
of it is very cinematic so I think it
would make a great movie or like a great
series or something like that so you
know gotta say my Kindle unlimited
roulette came through for me again
because this was this was a book that I
actually checked this out like a way
long time ago like I think when it first
came out like last fall or something
like that and I had forgotten that it
was in my checkouts and I was like
scrolling through and like checking in
books that I had forgotten to check in I
was like oh yeah I never read that one
it's like maybe I should get around to
it and so I'm glad I finally did and I'm
sorry it took so long but you know
because it's been in there for like
months and months but I'm glad I finally
got to it because I really really liked
it a lot and I think you will too uh
like I said if you're into you know Ray
Bradbury or Stephen King or something
like that it definitely it has its own
thing and it's like kind of more updated
than that I guess but it has that
similar kind of vibe to it so if you
like that kind of stuff then you'll
probably like this too so that will do
it for this tomes of Terror thank you
very much for watching Remember to like
share comment and all of that good stuff
for the algorithm and I'll see you guys
again next time bye